from the beaches of Florida to the
bright lights of Las Vegas businesses
and venues normally thriving with
activity and paying customers are
closing down almost no business is
exempt from the effects of the corona
virus as people increasingly self
isolate commercial air travel is being
hit hard but it's small businesses and
their employees that are among the most
vulnerable not sure if you've heard yet
but we are closing after today as
customers stay away in increasing
numbers the reality for those working
for themselves and employing others is
hitting hard I cried last night I'm a
pretty strong girl but um it's sad as
millions of schools closed their doors
those that rely on the education system
for a paycheck are being laid off some
economists are predicting unemployment
rates as high as 20 percent I'm guessing
somewhere between forty seven hundred
and fifty two hundred bus drivers all of
a sudden aren't working that's a lot of
people across the u.s. food banks a
vital lifeline for those living in
poverty is seeing a sharp decline in
volunteers donations to a drying up and
there has been actually less food as
people been hoarding that hasn't hit us
as hard though as the volunteers small
business owners are now in a dire
situation many have closed their doors
and don't know when they'll reopen
others have laid staff off for an
undetermined amount of time and all are
now looking to the federal government
for help and aid short term
interest-free loans may help for now but
long-term the future looks bleak plans
are now in place to help but only for
the next few weeks I think there's broad
general agreement that small businesses
in this country will not be able to
survive unless there's extraordinary
assistance and so the idea behind the
proposal that we are finalizing now is
the idea of how can we transfer money as
quickly as possible to help small
businesses meet payroll and operating
obligations for a period of time roughly
equivalent to six weeks the challenge
for many is safely getting food for
their families the small business owners
it's about staying afloat in an economic
crisis
it's likely to get worse and a Gallacher
al Jazeera Miami Florida